okay so House of the dragon is about to
do a big 10-year time Jump that will
pick up far after the events of episode
5. we also have two of the main
characters recast and I love how the
show has gone from debating who the true
air is to know who the true rhaenyra and
Alison are the trailer for episode 6 has
a lot going on with it and throughout
this video we're going to be breaking it
all down and going through what we think
is gonna happen based off the books
because of this there's gonna be big
spoilers so if you don't want anything
ruined then I recommend that you turn
off now pledge allegiance to havarus
Bulgarian by hitting the Subscribe
button and don't forget to smash the
thumbs up like it's lady Ria's head
without the way thank you for clicking
this I'm gonna play the trailer first
and then we'll get into everything that
we think happens in it
we should address the latest
developments in the steps turns my lords
where I wonder is our Prince Damon it
was a decade ago and he has since left
the region undefended we have left
undefended
my queen
what are children but a weakness
[Applause]
through them you imagine you will
persist forever
you will be our King
we are the blood of old Valeria
for them you surrender what you should
not
father compromised by the acts of the
sun Taiwan
a child like that is Mr
3 is an insult people have eyes
the consequences of an allegation like
the one you tired
okay so as mentioned earlier we pick up
10 years after the events of episode 5.
we open with caraxis AKA Damon's dragon
and learn that he's fled to the
stepstones with his wife Elena the pair
had several children together and in the
books though she was initially due to
wed someone from the three cities Damon
murdered them so that he could take the
spot nice tactic and the pair had two
children including Rayna and Baylor the
ladder of which was named after Damon
and viserys's father who was called
Balin Lena seems to have already had the
one and be pregnant with another though
this could end up being the third child
that the pair had which led to a big
tragedy now even though episode 5 ended
with viserys collapsing we see that he's
still alive in kicking a full decade
later though I knew this happened to him
in the books I actually thought that
they changed things up a bit and killed
him off earlier than they had in that
timeline even with the time Jump he's
still here though however he is
extremely weak you might notice that
he's sitting down during every shot in
the trailer and this is because he ended
up being almost unable to walk due to
the disease taking over his body Paddy
concert in recently cleared out that
this is actually a form of leprosy and
we've recently done a video discussing
his comments with Entertainment Weekly
which will be linked as the pin comment
that's on our Clips Channel which I hope
you guys subscribe to make sure you hit
that video right after this anyway this
is starting to cover his face and he
looks like how I feel after staying up
until 3am to post our 20 minute episode
breakdowns but I digress now the big
thing that he's getting angry about in
this teaser is that people keep
suggesting that ranera's children are
bastards and that they don't actually
belong to Lenor this is who she read in
the last episode but he was more gay nor
than lane or
cut that I'll definitely get canceled
over there now to set the stage the
books go into this in a lot more detail
and they said that after Kristen Cole
rejected raniera that he ended up
running up into the night which is where
she bumped into Harwin strong he ended
up taking her virginity and due to her
marriage with Elena having a hall pass
in it she started to have an affair with
him though Kristen turned her down he
still loved her but this and the wedding
proved 2 merch and he ended up growing
better and twisted this pushed him into
becoming Alison's Royal protector and he
became a staunch supporter of the greens
Harwin ended up becoming Rainier's lover
and the pair ended up having several
children together now why this caused a
lot of issues is because she of course
married Lionel but you could see that
the kids weren't related to him at all
the valerians of course have long white
hair and I think they might even tied
into the character's race although a
cries of the show going woke when the
valerians were revealed I actually think
this adds another dimension to it
rainer's kids are whiter than Jesse
Nelson and they don't even have a little
mix so it's clear that their Hall wins
which is a big room meant that beceros
has to shut down kind of feel sorry for
the guy and every week he's like oh [ __ ]
here we go again now this of course
angers Alison and we see several of her
kids in this new look they all knew the
kids were bastards and therefore
illegitimate heirs but the strongs were
actually regarded as being the next in
line due to the promise made to the
valerians it causes a lot of problems
and I think we might even see harwin's
strong striking Kristen at one point in
the Box Kristen ended up kicking the
crap out of him at one of the wedding
tournaments and he broke both his
collarbone and elbow this led to him
being called Harwin break bones and he
should call me Harwin breakdown say oh
you suck now ironically Hoenn and
raniera could have been married without
all this controversy surrounding them if
his dear old dad had suggested him as a
Suitor during episode three Owen is
known as the strongest man in the Seven
Kingdoms and he's gonna be a big
character going forward Now Alison is
also wearing green and her and raniera
are now clearly enemies in the books it
was said that the pair never got along
but I'm glad they made them friends
first so that we get even more drama
when they fall out with each other now I
believe that we see aemond in this
teaser and that they make some of the
things here with aegon including the
scuffle that they have with Joffrey
that name again now Joffrey elonmouth
was of course Leno's lower and they
ended up naming one of their kids after
him one night Eamon snuck out of his bed
to attempt to ride the dragon vagar and
Geoffrey popped up and then started
shouting at him Eamon called him a
strong and kicked him into some Dragon
manure before he jumped onto Vega now
the kick seems to be carried out much
earlier in the day by who I believe is
aegon lucerys Valerian ended up cutting
out eamon's eye because of theirs and he
was later known as aemond one eye Alison
demanded that his eye should be cut out
as well which I think we might see
playing out here it was very much gonna
be an eye for an eye but viserys put his
foot down and said there would be
nothing of the sort in the end Eamon
said that he lost an eye that day but he
gained a dragon so all in all it was a
fair trade-off however the Rivalry
continued with them still not believing
the children were legitimate as because
of this renera demanded that anyone who
said such a thing should be thought of
as committing treason and we get a
potential nod to one of these
punishments in the book look I put on
screen we have a picture of an eye
getting cut out and also the punishment
for anyone who called them strongs this
included cutting someone's tongue out he
said it and as I'm sure you can guess
[ __ ] just couldn't keep their mouth
shut so this of course ended up
happening which I think we could get a
tease towards during a time in which the
king had it carried out on two people he
slipped in sliced his hand on the throne
it was at this point in the story that
he got a fever and had his fingers
removed whereas in the show it happened
a lot earlier with none of the strongs
being born I don't care though I'll say
they're strong as I don't give a you
can't hurt me though they're all a bunch
of bloody
[Laughter]
now rumors of this of course still
persisted and I think there's a lot
going to happen in this upcoming episode
obviously the targaryens have bright
blonde hair and the valerians are white
so it's gonna be pretty easy to tell
that there might just be one of the
Bloodlines I think this is what anger's
Alison so much as she's well aware of
the illegitimacy of it and it's even
more frustrating because her and her
father gave up a lot to get their kids
on the throne now on the other side of
this are Damon and his wife who to see
themselves as being legitimate we even
see them getting a dragon egg and this
was of course placed in The Cribs of
Targaryen children so that they could
form a bond this is something that Damon
wanted to do for the child he wished to
have with mazaria but it was taken away
from him I think it might be the same
egg that was gonna be used on the air
for a day baby Balin and somehow Damon
has managed to get it back either way
this is setting up a big event in the
timeline called the red spring in which
several of the main characters die I
leave some of the others having to marry
and form alliances in order to keep
things strong harwin's strong you could
say no no got nothing to do with him
that was a crap pun but they are
definitely setting up a lot of things
here I am interested to see how it all
plays out and I hope the recast works
even though I would have preferred the
two main actors to just have been aged
up with makeup we are getting what we're
getting though and of course let me know
your thoughts on the teaser below we are
in a competition right now and giving
away three copies of Thor love and
thunder on the 15th of October and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on drop a
comment below with your thoughts on the
trailer you pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one are on screen right now
save that to you then message me on
Twitter at heavy spoilers you son of a
[ __ ] if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
Brighton of episode 5 which will be
linked on screen right now one of our
bestest videos ever not hard to top the
ones like this but go ahead over there
right after this now the way thanks for
sticking to the video I've been poor and
see you next time take care peace